saved by the bell is a show that defined
the 90s
filled with topical lessons of the era
and some questionable fashion statements
but nothing's more memorable than the
theme song and there's one guy to thank
[Music]
meet scott gayle the man responsible for
all the music for save by the bell i'm
scott gale
my resume would include 2 000 episodes
of network television including
say by the bell the golden girls empty
nest i know there's some others in there
i first started getting interested in
music
when i saw elvis presley on television
on the ed sullivan show
[Music]
i said i want to do that and i was about
five years old luckily my parents
arranged guitar lessons for me
i first moved to la in 1972.
my first big break was music coordinator
i worked on every episode of the golden
globes
[Music]
i got the first call at the very end of
89 from the producers about working on a
new television show and it was going to
be called say by the bell they told me
that it might make seven episodes maybe
not so
i put the phone down
two minutes later the song came out of
me by the time i grab my books and i
give myself a look i'm at the corner
just in time to see the bus fly by it's
all right cause i'm sad by the bell
and uh i'd say it was like the luckiest
two minutes of my life and when they
heard mine they said that's it that's it
i heard later that they did not want the
name of the show in the title but i did
not get that note
saved by the bell was competing with
cartoons at the time because saturday
morning on nbc there was no live action
for kids so everything needed to be
brash and happy and and lots of
visual and lots of color
peter ingle the executive producer he
always told us want rock i wanted to be
happy i wanted to be driving and i
wanted to rock no matter what the scene
was he wanted to rock
[Music]
most of the music was
story oriented
[Music]
if there was a car crash or a breakup
scene
we write to the picture and we even
wrote rap we did the best we could
i'm not really a rapper but we uh we
laid down a beat and the kids really
they they made the
songs come to life look you sexist pigs
and that's no lie you could treat me
like this and i'll stay at the y
i really love working on today by the
bell because we had an opportunity to to
write and perform so much music a lot of
people growing up in the 90s that was
their show people could relate to it
i still am a fan of the show it comes on
all the time and i never get tired of
watching it and i never get tired of
seeing my name on the screen
it's all right because i'm sad by the
bell
almost